let's go next to our caller from the
three-to-one area I'm not kidding by the
way I know that sounded sarcastic but
it's cool to get a call from Google
Hangouts why not uh it's either country
code 32 or area code three-to-one I
can't tell but I hope I hope you know
who I'm talking to
hello yeah that's you oh that's weird um
so I had a couple questions because um I
seem to talk on the show a couple times
about how you don't really agree with
the idea of primary and corporate
Democrats because it might be messy and
Rob you alright
no no that's I've never said that what
I've said is that just because there is
a corporate Democrat that we might like
to replace with a more progressive
Democrat in some cases what our limited
resources might be better spent trying
to win a seat currently held by a
Republican or working on instead of
primary
accor pura Democratic senator may be
trying to win two congressional races so
I've never said I'm against primary and
corporate Democrats what I've said is
it's not your the best strategy right
like something we have to think
critically and sometimes there's other
ways to spend our money yeah but I still
disagree with that because I think that
it's it's kind of conceding the fight
before you even start because corporate
Democrats are just as much or not just
as much but they're a large part of the
problem just as like like the
Republicans are because you can tell by
recent elections and and the reset
debacle with Democratic Party doug jones
being elected and basically agreeing
with the republicans the senate a lot of
time I don't want to interrupt you but I
think you because you brought up Doug
Jones this is actually gets right to the
heart of it you're right I would much
rather have a real progressive in the
Senate as a Democrat then Doug Jones but
let's think about for a second what the
circumstances are we're talking about
Alabama right by putting resources into
primary doug jones if anything you
make it more likely that a Republican
gets that seat back so like if you came
to and you said we've got 10 million
bucks pick all the ways to spend the
money I don't know
hold on a second I don't know that
primary the Alabama Democratic senator
is the best way to go about it yeah and
indulgence might not be the best example
but I just in terms of like corporate
Democrats okay cause Alabama is deeply
red but I mean the idea of of just kind
of giving them a pass and not putting
any pressure on them because you know it
might be hard in other states to go to
support but I write states I think that
when we're actually you know in other
states I might agree with you it's it's
like you you called in and you said you
disagree with my position that sometimes
it's not the smartest thing and then I
gave you one example and you agreed with
me you said well actually maybe an
Alabama you're right but I'm talking
about other states I I agree in other
states maybe it is the right strategy
but it sounds like you and I actually
agree that in Alabama it might not be
and thus you're kind of agreeing with me
which is it's not the right strap yeah
but in a hundred percent yeah and and I
feel like Alabama's just like is
literally like if you take the 50 states
that you probably like the three states
where the argument really applies but
three or four states that are working
really applies but I feel like um from
watching your show did that overall you
you aren't that much behind like like
the Justice Democrats and and just like
a huge movement that specifically meant
to target primary corporate dimmer
no I'm not I'm not sure how else I can
say it or you don't or you don't think
it's the best option I don't think it's
the best option in every race but even
you agreed with that like you agreed in
Alabama it's not the best option yeah
yeah and it's just the larger point of
just the corporate Democrats being the
problem like the the FISA vote and and
the deregulation of Wall Street and here
folding to or not voting to end the war
in Yemen like things like that they're
really a large part of the problem that
feel like there
like they're being kind of ignored just
you know build up this blue wave and
people are afraid to really even just
just mention it or call it out because
they feel like they're starting
infighting but I feel like that's just
as important as as getting like I'm
getting rid of the Republicans or we
were probably a majority in Congress
because the elected that like if you get
here's where we agree corporate
Democrats are a big problem
here's where we disagree I think if you
get the choice of replacing Ted Cruz
with a corporate Democrat or replacing
Joe Manchin with a slightly more liberal
Democrat but Ted Cruz stays I think
we're better off removing a Republican
senator from Texas then moving the West
bringing in a Republican senator in West
Virginia with the possibility of getting
rid of Joe Manchin but Ted Cruz stays
just a disagreement that's where we
disagree you know I appreciate the call
though it's a really really important
thing and I think it's just I think we
mostly agree I think it's just the
degree to where we are on the spectrum
is I think maybe maybe where we differ